こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
皆様は白猫テニスというゲームやったことがありますでしょうか
僕もめちゃくちゃやってるんですけども
白猫テニスの中でユニークなラケットが沢山あります
皆さん白猫テニスやったことある方なら
多分思い当たる節があると思うんですけども
あれは果たして本当に実際にテニスで使うと
使えるのかどうかという検証を今回していこうと思います
ベテランのテニスプレイヤーの方と実際にテニスをしてみようと思います
勝ちますよ
できれば勝ちにいきたいですけど
本当にあれ実用的なのかどうかっていうのを知りたいので
今回そちらを確かめていきたいと思います
ではいこう
はいというわけで今回こちらの
ベテランテニスプレイヤー：一応...
はじめ：どれくらいちなみにテニスやられていますか？
軽くちょっとベテランの方の実際のテニスを受けてみようと思います
ひとまずサーブを受けてみましょう
よろしくお願いします
wwwwww
はいというわけで準備は万端でございます
まず最初に使うラケットはこちら
バットです
白猫テニスでこういうバットみたいラケットがあるんで
これで本当に打ち返せるか実際にやっていこうと思います
よろしくおねがいしまーす
わあああおっおっほ
音がやべーぞ
返せる感じはあったんで次で返します
UUUMのシールが
あわわUUUMのシールが
取りました
ダメです
素人の僕だと当たらなかったので
ベテランの方に今回やっていただこうと思います
これで返せたら白猫テニス本物ですからね
さあ返せるのか
続いてはこちら
メガホンです
そもそも打つ物でもないという
でもこういうラケットがあるので
こちらもひょっとしたら打ち返すことができるかもしれません
ではやっていきましょう
次はこちら
フライパンです
フライパン意外と形はなんかラケットっぽいんで
返そうと思えば返せそうな気もします
やってみましょう
あーーきた
あ、いいよいいよ
僕でも結構フライパンで返せたんで
これひょっとしたら出来る方に
ベテラン：これ..なら
はじめ：イケそうですよね？
おほほほwww
すっげww
すげー
続いてはこちら
ピコピコハンマーです
そもそもこれ圧縮するんで
なかなかこれで返すのは難しいですし
音も出ちゃうんで
じゃあやってみます
おなしゃす！
あっ！キタ！
イケる！
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
はいというわけで白猫テニスのラケットは
使えるやつもあれば
使えないやつもありました
た
だ
やっぱ勝ちたいっしょ
やっぱり彼らには僕勝ちたいので今回特別に
最強のラケット準備しました
ここ2つ分くっ付いてるんで
ガットが2つあるんですよ
なので反動を活かして
2倍こう強い威力で跳ね返るんで
これでキラキラ光るんで相手の目を翻弄して
トドメを刺そうと思います
ミラのモチーフラケットみたいな感じですね
ではいきます
いくぞーーーーー！
アーーーーーーーーッ♂
というわけで白猫テニス皆さま遊んでますでしょうか
操作性がすごい簡単なので誰でも簡単に楽しめるので
ゲームが苦手なあなたでも楽しめると思います
そしてダブルスもできるので友達と一緒にゲームを楽しむこともできます
是非友達とやってみてください
そしてなんといっても
白猫と言えばキャラクターが可愛いでございます
僕の愛しのシャルロットも白猫テニスで使えるので
皆さん是非可愛いキャラクターを見つけて使ってみてください
今ならこんなキャンペーンもやってまーす
今から始める方チャンスです！是非やってみてくださーい
そして
さっきボロ負けしたベテランのテニスプレイヤーの方たちと
僕のサブチャンの方で白猫テニスの方で戦っております
実践で無理ならゲームで勝つしかないよな
動画の概要欄にサブチャンネルの動画もあります
ダウンロードもできますので是非皆さん遊んでみてください
じゃあな！